Pardon c’est bon ?
Bonjour à tous, et bienvenue dans...
J’ai pas regardé, vas-y.
J’suis désolé.
Oui oui, t’inquiètes.
Bonjour à tous, et bienvenue dans...
Je suis Léo.
Je suis Pierre.
Toujours.
Nan, t’es pas obligé de dire ça…
Ouais, c’est vrai… Non, ouais, non.
On plonge des invités dans des situations cocasses...
Et à l’aide d’un habile système d’oreillette, on les guide dans des défis un peu rigolos !
Et aujourd’hui, on va accueillir …
Quentin !
Ça va ! T’es bien !
Je fais un petit bisou à Amaury du coup, parce qu’il est…
Il est pas là !
C’est pas nécessaire !
Aujourd’hui...
On est dans une salle de sport...
Donc tu vas nous piéger les abonnés de cette salle de sport !
J’ai l’impression que … il a une grande notoriété en ce moment.
J’ai peur que les gens le reconnaissent.
C’est possible. C’est vrai, juste...
Ophélie ? Juste, faire un petit Makeup ?
Voilà ! Qu’on ne le reconnaisse pas trop, tu vois.
Nickel.
Est-ce que t’es prêt, Quentin ?
Mouais bof bof, mais euh …
C’est parti !
On l’a raté complètement…
Tu peux la poser et frapper dedans, contre le mur ?
Prends de l’élan un petit peu et tire dedans.
Refais !
Tu peux demander à un mec de faire le goal ?
Ça vous dirait pas de vous mettre là et j’essaye de…
J’essaye de marquer des buts ?
Vous vous mettez là...
Et vous vous mettez comme ça.
Et j’essaye de-de-de...
Faut qu’il arrête... Faut qu’il arrête les buts.
Faut l’arrêter hein !
Ouais.
Hé pas mal !
Encore un ?
Encore un petit.
Hééé pas mal !
Tu peux aller prendre si tu veux l’espèce de petit euh … le petit socle ?
Là, les petites euh... Les petites bouées là !
Tu te mets dessus puis tu fais des petits... Des petits sauts de trampoline.
Et tu te demandes au Monsieur à ta droite si c’est comme ça qu’il faut faire.
Vous savez comment ça... Comment ça marche ?
Vous vous mettez en position squat comme ça...
Position squat...
Prends lui par les mains, prends lui par les mains. Ok.
Mais j’ai l’impression que c’est hyper euh...
C’est la première fois que je …
Tu peux tomber et, lui tomber dessus mais euh…
Un peu langoureusement ?
Je suis un peu seul en ce moment…
En ce moment, je suis tout seul donc...
Vous êtes tout seul aussi, non ?
Vous êtes... Vous êtes tout seul aussi, non ?
Le mec lui dit rien…
Arrête de lui parler et fais des roulades dans toute la salle.
Tu le mets un peu plus haut, le...
La barre, et tu fais du limbo.
Ok, c’est ça !?
Allez mais viens, tu veux essayer !
C’est sûr qu’il a envie d’essayer ! C’est sûr, c’est évident.
Moi, je pense qu'il passe pas.
En même temps... Il a même pas fait un limbo !
Tu peux faire un exercice, et mimer une foulure ?
Et tu fais du cloche-pied dans toute la salle.
Voilà.
Putain !
Fais le tour de la cage, fais le tour de la cage.
Personne va l’aider, c’est fou !
Vas-y encore… Ouah la vache !
Essaye d’aller un peu plus vite, voilà !
Ils s’en branlent, ils s’en branlent les gens !
Fais-lui la vanne au mec qui est assis... Tu le, tu le...
Tu lui fais enlever ses écouteurs et tu lui dis « Tu veux un café ? »
Tu veux un petit thé ?
On dirait vraiment que c’est euh…
Une théière...
C’est une théière, quoi !
Du coup je propose du thé, quoi !
Café sinon !
Tu peux demander à quelqu’un de te tenir les jambes ?
Excusez-moi ?
Ça vous dérangerait juste de me tenir les jambes ?
Ah yes, super !
Moi, je viens à la salle un peu pour reconquérir ma meuf !
Et ouais, j’avais mon ex qui faisait du hand…
Il est reparti avec ses écouteurs…
Le mec qui fout rien à la salle !
T’es trop bien là !
Continue de tourner !
C’est trop facile en fait !
Putain la vache !
Tu peux le refaire ? Voilà !
Allez, tout le monde avec moi ! Ok, c’est parti !
Allez, c’est parti ! On va se chauffer un petit peu là !
Tous les bras en l’air ! Allez !
Est-ce que vous êtes chauds ?!
J’entends rien ! Est-ce que vous êtes chauds ?! Allez !
J’entends rien !
J’entends vraiment rien là…
Elle est vachement bien celle-là !
C’est ma préférée.
Je sais pas comment te le dire, mais ‘fin ça me dérange tu t’utilises celle-là, en fait…
Bah après j’étais dessus, mais…
fais toi plais’ hein !
On peut en faire ensemble, hein, si tu veux...
Essaye de le pousser un petit peu...
On peut faire un concours !
Est-ce que tu veux pas essayer de faire un... un méga jenga ? Et essayer d’empiler...
Tous les demi-ballons qu’il y a derrière toi ?
Si quelqu’un peut m’aider à... A les empiler, ça serait cool de votre part.
Vous voulez pas m’aider à en emmener là-bas ?
Si vous pouvez l’amener là-bas...
Un ou deux...
Ou trois, trois, trois…
Hé c’est gagné, là !
C’est à chier !
Tu peux demander si quelqu’un peut te prendre en photo devant ton œuvre, s’il-te-plait ?
Je voulais... Je … essayer de sauter au-dessus …
On t’a pas dit de sauter mais fais-le si tu le sens !
Prépare-toi mentalement et physiquement.
Allez !
Mets-toi accroupi devant, et tu fais le signe de Jul.
Et tu te fais mal, hein !
C’est ridicule… C’est ridicule à souhait !
On espère que vous avez aimé ce premier épisode de "Gag dans l'oreillette" !
On se retrouve bientôt avec Oria qui devra piéger les clients d’une boutique de cosmétique !